welcome to this video playing has a
rocket the rocket from Denmark and he's
going to sort of close sicilian
territory or let's say f four grown free
attack something like that against the
french down um let's see 94 maybe i'm
not sure maybe also this is an idea and
then if I've gaining the space here I
one now
for Doby should be six maybe a fire far
maybe at five
I don't know I cannot just a lot think
for ages about this position so should
be ok but like okay so how exactly do i
go here maybe be five Bishop a six I can
also still casts a long that's very
important I have not cancelled short
this this this would be really dangerous
if I would have castled short him will
be three years is good news I like that
giving me this direct opportunity to
play on the queenside yeah do I want to
exchange this or what exactly is the
best plan
I can actually do this yeah this is
quite good c3 Bishop see one Bishop a
three or maybe even oh it's not doing
that route be 8 p-2 also interesting
directly attacking day to pawn I have
night before coming this is this is very
difficult or ready to protect my king is
okay in the center he has no attack wats
island
yeah I wonder right before this must be
must be must be dangerous whatwhat
dangerous-looking move might be noisy
forward threatening on C to wear with
check and also on d3 possibly like
Bishop d3 r93 when the night on f 2 News
the results a penny on the second ranked
by the rook this really looks like
difficult to play mouth even yeah this
one
it's no direct win I can take a tool
it's also just good problem and come in
a fryer to a taxi to so don't see how he
defends it he doesn't but down there
also was no defense okay with the queen
or not totally sure totally sure what's
best Queen takes you might have night
you want at the end but i'm not sure i
can i can take with the roof should be
should be okay in any case night you
want now still and still 91 yes hmm
okay maybe I have I only have this move
here 91 would be too young and here
still rugby too i guess some so that i
get to get rid get out of this this
strange pin here
that's still a very very untidy position
somewhat confusing can easily make some
some mistake I wanted to prevent Nyjah
for him
let's let's see I can get some some
direct attack it going h5 is hanging
okay a seven is hanging time morning id3
in a very confusing position
I can take here but I wasn't really sure
check
check 28 seconds
oh man what a mess
I'm promoting it should be enough but
those pawns are really a check really
quite a quite the nuisance but ok that
that's it yeah rook a 3 or look on the
first record check winning okay whoo
what a crazy game check check and check
me boo yeah hell out far more
counterplay than was necessary out of
this position really night c2m is some
jack is even stronger yeah once you once
you see it on the board you're pretty
much good they see that this is very
strong I am he must take my what else is
there and then my palm with Bishop
before I just promoting okay it's much
stronger well this is all like minus 5
and so on but it's it's totally totally
wacky see two wins okay maybe this is
all like minus 8 but i'm not sure about
here this is this now yeah yeah this is
this is no problem bishop d1 is good for
word so even even winning forward okay
it's a total mess i'm on 40 seconds he
can even he can take now yeah my piece
is so are not coordinated here
why twins yeah and here I don't know
chat heads just totally chaotic check
computers on on when I win for right now
is g6 and this is losing minus 11 yeah
it's a crapshoot he was also not playing
on position anymore just on time just
playing anymore and um I can't I just
check I must miss made him otherwise
I'll lose on time poor very a very
extreme position okay thanks for
watching